[Music]
and chicken lover muse ah chicken lover
haha by not Batman who the [__] cares
about you
a man pled guilty to sexually assaulting
a chicken and now has to register as a
[__] sex offender he's a chicken
[__] well yeah cuz you don't just go
you don't just start with just chicken
[__] you're gonna mean like you got to
ease your way you're a farmer you start
with you so you think there's a gateway
animal that you [__] first before you go
to chickens was a hundred percent sure
that that's the gateway I mean that's
the gateway [__] they stopped it before
he went to goats and cows because that
[__] chicken died I'm a hundred this
is a chicken right and the average human
penis is what like this big the avid
come on
how did he get caught [__] a chicken
really six six I think this is not six
inches no this is like what are six
inches I'm cutting a ruler how did he
get caught [__] a chicken yeah was he
at the egg farm Cletus is [__] one of
the chickens how do you [__] a chicken
cuz they squirm like I've owned a
chicken so that means he had to befriend
this chicken that's sick I think he
ain't a chicken with this cuz I've ever
seen
chicken [__] it's a whole it's just the
anal right yeah it's just always both I
think they have to cuz birds they poo
and pee on the same hole they do I don't
know I befriended the chicken before
yeah but they squirm around too much
when like unless you're used to you
touch them the right way you know you're
not seducing them right yep yeah maybe
yours too roughly - yeah yeah that's
fine I picked up chickens yeah I picked
them up - I picked the plants chickens
and the chickens love me I picked up the
chickens and put it on my lap didn't
[__] him though me neither [__] I didn't
[__] them but if I wanted to I could
have
I'm pretty sure if you [__] chicken is
dead see that you can die no no I got a
little dick to fit in the chicken ass
okay oh I can't even imagine that you
know how dirty the [__] chicken's ass
and [__] claws are it's full of
cocking feathers and she's probably
clean though cuz that's they have a
short digestive system so soon as they
eat they shoot it out right away
but there's probably gravel and [__]
yeah [__] chickens be sitting on the
floor all the time but the feathers
cover is the feathers are like this it
covers up the bunny smell bad they don't
smell bad yeah you feel bad for eating
chickens as much as you do cows I feel
bad for eating all sorts of meat even
fish everything
what about pancakes no but you're eating
a chicken's food no but for noon
really yeah I feel bad eating eggs warm
excited I feel bad what do you milk to
so this man no puss so every day you
feel bad while you eat yeah that's why
you don't like food you're so conflicted
I know
I [__] love pork though and that's
like a [__] Mexican thing to you guys
how do you guys do it you guys cook pork
like [__] geniuses because I don't
really like my pork chop pork chops
[__] basic yeah [__] that [__]
I like southern well before you guys
take it off with all just only food let
me tell you about the chicken lover yeah
you [__] chicken [__]
27 years old you were again [__] you
know chicken throats do kind of look
like labias I would have thought the
chickens throw back because harsh so
what he did is that he exposed himself
and came in contact with a chickens
gentle genitals so that's what he did
I don't know they don't they don't
really feel a focus a [__] day he
flashed a chicken I don't know I said
the chicken was like
[Laughter]
and I went to with other chicken Hamid
[Music]
this conversation and which chicken was
offended yeah and then according to
court documents he also threatened a man
with six around the time of the incident
the sticks oh yeah so I wish I knew like
the entire story when I don't I just
know the charges against him and so
there's like a chicken in court right
now my [__] get you can you point to
the offender [__] this just wing in a
blue dress got some ducks behind their
[__] saying they were operating the
story so a few days after that incident
that's when he was arrested and he was
charged with sexual assault of an animal
public indecency menacing and
second-degree disorderly conduct [__]
yeah you [__] gonna receive
reparations I am how many other chickens
did he [__] did he does he have a
chicken coop or did he have a favorite
one I don't know but I should tell you
guys though is that he does suffer from
mental health issues I think so he was
straight from the start cuz I don't
think anybody in their straight man
wants to [__] chickens yeah I don't I
don't see a chicken cross the road and
be like oh my god doesn't roll no I'm
just thinking like I'm trying to put
myself in this perspective but did he
see some skin and he got horny or like
you know if I can make a chicken or what
is the chicken look like maybe okay so
you said he's not mentally right so he
has bipolar disorder oh [__] ADHD and
they're the course none of those things
make people [__] check
with you guys this is like absurd I have
ADHD okay I'm really thought it was
something else cuz then I was gonna say
oh it's a it's a learned behavior you
know he must have seen to a rooster [__]
a chicken and he was like oh I believe
well there's the court documents do
seems to be functions at the level of a
seven-year-old what I don't know any 7
year olds that try to [__] a chicken
well well it's different though because
he's mentally seven but physical
hormones wise he has to [__] something
and he might not know what [__] is so
he has something more than just
bipolarism in ADHD yeah yeah he's seven
they don't mention what it is well that
makes sense now when I go back to my
previous statement he probably was like
it feels good when I do this with my
we're but I've never witnessed a seven
you know trying to [__] the chicken
though oh I know but I'm just saying he
has his urges Oh still a man's ball sack
but seven-year old mine yeah so it's
like when you rub up against like like
it's a kid I just I've heard stories
from like guys where they're like oh
like you you guys have even said it like
you guys rub up against something don't
know what it is be like that feels good
I just like climbing trees oh because it
felt good right yeah I was rubbing my
dragging my ballsack in my dick across
the [__] tree branches so maybe was
the safer he that's true because I like
to give my friends hugs but then they
were turned around this way and their
butt was on my Weiner gross the
backwards hug like this a guy girls oh
then it's like dancing and then you
wouldn't your hips would move no it was
a sexual thing I just knew that the butt
all right all my hips felt good
God didn't you guys were [__]
sexually active as kids I don't over any
of that [__] yeah well I play with toys
but I didn't make the connection that it
was a sexual thing the human I just knew
that it felt good like a hug felt good
yeah Joshua here he also so last year in
2016 he was convicted of fourth fourth
degree assault for punching his mother
any man oh this guy's a wild child
first-degree criminal trespassing after
he illegally entered a home and
methamphetamine position
Oh what the [__] yeah I think he's on
meth that would make it a little bit
more sense cuz I feel so bad that this
they know that this man operates with a
seven-year-old mind to charge him with
all this [__] I feel like that's not
fair but I mean he's old enough to buy
some [__] meth and go back bball and
it pushed his mom in the face yeah the
punching the mom in the face I still
would attribute that to seven-year-old
behavior well I'm just I'm just like the
media they're just kind of painting this
guy to being this oh he's kind of like
mentally not there and all that stuff
man he don't give a [__] he's gonna [__]
chickens he's gonna do it he's good he's
on a rampage he's trailer trash man [__]
this guy I find it very odd that
somebody would say well why did he do it
well he clearly has ADHD what else yeah
he does man you should lead with that I
think that is the thing yeah you should
leave he was and he started [__] the
couch I can't tell you everything oh I
wasn't blaming I mean I was saying
that's [__] crazy then in court that
they're saying ADHD is one of the bigger
reasons what really is probably the best
what why why was the raping the the
bedsheets why is why yeah it's that's I
don't know why did he open up the
[__] refrigerator and start [__]
the 2-liter bottle of coke bipolar it
makes no [__] sense and then you go
oh in a little bit of meth yeah that's
the main thing
oh man I don't know if I could let my
kid punch me in the face but if you get
but I don't know I'll still beat up my
seven-year-old oh yeah I punch it back
well because the seven is a seven year
old but if it's a if it's a older kid
with the mind of a seven year old it's
kind of like a dog when your dog yeah
you beat the [__] knows I bet you
anyone's you have 100 oh I'm sorry
[Laughter]
[__] [__] I bet you the mom did a
lot of drugs when she had a kid that's
why he grew up in and he punched her in
her face [__]
or she was a great mother and it was
just a genetic thing I don't believe
that he's held again 27 in farmland an
Oregon and he's [__] chickens all day
keep him away from my chicken coop I got
foxes to worry about now this chicken
[__] - what's next man this guy's
gonna be in my koi pond [__] - my koi
and [__] now he's a registered sex
offender so he can't kind of crazy
that's dope I don't care no I think I
think it's a little crazy that he [__]
the chicken and now he's a registered
sex offender
I'm going to defend it in court what the
chicken came up with the [__] docs
wearing the [__] balls I see a
chicken in a [__] blue bonnet dress
and she's out here say chicken [__] I
watched his mother in the fax I want to
see that chicken point out - another
chicken toy and say where did he touch
you see that [__] I want to see all the
farm animals kind of like ganging up and
saying like my duties were squeezed and
then like all these come out I wouldn't
believe the cow though cuz that she has
to get her TV squeeze no I just see the
[__] cow just in it with hella add
two in the corner own it what you
talking about you know what you see mrs.
cow sure
and in buckin what was his name
Templeton Templeton Templeton the [__]
wilted the pink wimpleton the pig hey
you guys want to stock any of us we'll
go ahead down to the description box
below and you can follow us on Instagram
and all kinds of stuff for more videos